il découvre aujourd'hui là où poussent
les fruits qu'ils ont dégusté durant
tout le confinement des goyave gorgés de
soleil des masses ici des délices de la
nature qui ont compensé l'absence de
promenade en pleine nature
chaque semaine en fait il propose une
liste de produits aux clients et c'est
vrai que pendant le confinement ça a été
vraiment très intéressant parce que là
on a pu continuer à consommer en fait
les produits locaux à être livré un
service vitamines et dont plusieurs des
clients ici présents se sont délectés
tout en étant protégé de lakovic 19 ans
cherchait surtout à ne pas sortir
on cherchait surtout à temps toute
sécurité pendant locaux vides donc à
récupérer des produits du terroir
donc c'était le bel endroit je
connaissais déjà mais plus
pédagogiquement parlant parce qu'on a
fait des sorties des élèves
mais là vraiment une re découverte avec
des produits de chez nous des produits
inconnus aussi ses nouveaux clients lui
il les appelle ses clients que vides qui
m'ont soutenu pendant cette période
mon permis de ne pas licencier ni maître
chômage partiel mais ouvriers là je suis
dans une dynamique où la vente est
assurée sur les clients passant commande
voilà et donc ça me permet d'assurer ma
production et l'avant donc je sais ce
que je le vend et tout est clair ça me
permet vraiment d'optimiser grâce au
confinement il a vu son chiffre
d'affaires augmenter de près de 30%
s'est également tournée vers la vente
directe en ouvrant ce petit marché en
hommage à sa mère clotilde celle qui lui
a donné le goût de l'agriculture illégal
et j'ai vu mes informations les îlots
sais pas mais je suis angoissé l'émotion
oui est ce que tu penses avec un jour
stein on annonce via mais en innovant
durant ce confinement
ils ont aussi offert une toute jeune
génération le goût du terroir comme je
les dis ceci il ya beaucoup de choix
je me raconte bien totalement tout ça
j'en mange toujours 37 ans de passion
pour cette terre une passion inter
générationnel pour à coup sûr un futur
toujours plus fructueux